معنا مباشره من كيا فيولي ساك مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني مرحبا بكم معنا سيد يوري
في اخبار الساعه من العربيه بدايه الى اين
وصلت القوات الاوكرانيه في خيرصون
عذرا لقد انقطع الصوت قليلا
عنه اليوم
مختلفه في منطقه خيرسون ونحن نتقدم بشكل
تدريجي ومستقر نعم لماذا تشكك اوكرانيا في
الانسحاب الروسي من غير سون سيد يوري
نصف كابتك والله
بانسحابهم لانه ليس ان انسحاب تراجع لان
الجيش الاوكراني منذ عده اسابيع وهو يتسبب
المشاكل للجيش الروسي
ضربات جويه عاليه الدقلت عرقلت عملياتهم
اللوجستيه وسلاسل التموين في الجيش الروسي
في خرسان محاصر
على التموين
وفي نفس الوقت
ولم نشهد الى الان حركه كبيره للجنود فما
لم نعم نعم غادرت القوات الروسيه فسوف
نستمر
بحجمتنا مضاده وماذا نفعله بكل دقه
وسننتصرف وفقا لخططتنا طيب ايه اذا لم يعد
الروس لمهاجمتكم في خيرس من المناطق التي
ينصحبو منها
واستمريتم في التقدم هل يمكن الحديث على
ان خلصن الان باتت نقطه تحول في الحرب في
اوكرانيا
العديد همم
اولها كان بعد ساعتين من بدايه هذا الغزو
يعني الكل كان يعتقد انه كان ستسقطه خلال
72 ساعه ولم تسقط اوكرانيا قاتل بكل شجاعه
وقلنا بحمايه عاصمتها
ولكن سيد يري هل يمكن ان يكون هذا
الانسحاب الروسي التكتيكي ربما هو
مفتاحا للمجال من اجل التفاوض المباشر ما
بين همم ما بينكم ما بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
لان هذه الحرب ام لا يعني هذا يعني مبالغه
او يعني همم شيء مثال جدا
نحن
العدو الروسي يرغب بالتفاوض لانهم بحاجه
الى وقف العمليات هم بحاجه الوقت لاعاده
التمويل والتدريب
للقواتيم او جنودهم الذين حشدهم
مؤخرا لانهم وصلوا الى ساحه المعركه غير
مستعدين باعداد كبيره ومتاكد انك شاهدت
الماضيه الجنود الروسيه
الى 80000 الف شكر
لانهم يرغبون بالشراء ولكن بالواقع روسيا
لن تستسلم ابدا ولن تتخلى عن حلمها
باحتلال اوكرانيا وتدميرها ونحن لنا نثق
باي حديث عن المفاوضات ولكن فيما يخصهمنا
زهره
والتعويضات ايرانيه يجب ان تدفع وكل شيء
يجب ان يتم وفقا لميثاق الامم المتحده بعد
ذلك بامكان الجلوس للتحدث ولكن سيد يوري
الا تخشون ان هذا الانسحاب الروسي كما
ذكرتهم انكم يعني تكبدون عشرات القتلى من
الجنود الروسي يوميا الا تخشون ان هذا
الانسحاب المفاجئ من من غيرسون يمهد
لاستخدام اسلحه غير تقليديه لان خلص في
النهايه هي همم تعتبرها روسيا انها
احتلتها وضمتها الى الى اراضيها بعد
الاستفتاءات التي قامتها قامتها في تلك
المنطقه الى اي حتى تخشون من ان روسيا
مقبله بعد هذا الانسحاب على تغيير منح
الحرب استخدام اسلحه غير تقليديه
رمضان
شامل
هذا المنظور تخوفنا
عنك
القنبله يدويه فالسنه لاحقا
ليس لها
عسكري ولا انسان
بعداد كبيره
لهم تلقوا رساله واضحه جدا من المجتمع
الدولي من اللاعبين الكبار على المسرح
الدولي وقيل لهم واضحه
باستخدام لانه تركيه
ستكون هذه نهايه روسيا هم يعرفوا ذلك
لا دفاع الاوكراني شكرا جزيلا لك على
تربيه دعوه العربيه هذا المساء